hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay the subject in power michel
foucault is going to make a really
important distinction for understanding
his works but i would also say for
understanding how power works
about the ways in which power relations
take shape and i would say in the ways
in which they're imposed but that
already is to import a kind of viewpoint
or a set of assumptions on power
relations that tends to make them into
relations of domination as opposed to
the other modes or modalities of power
relations that he's distinguishing and
so he talks about three types of
struggle against power and this means
against power relations
and he tells us that
what are these against forms of
domination
against forms of exploitation
and against forms
of
what he calls subjectivity and
submission and we're here just going to
call it subjection right
so
these are distinct from each other and
if we don't
maintain at least the conceptual
distinction between them we're lying
we're liable to blur them into each
other and thereby to mistake the ways in
which power actually works and the
relationships that set it up so
he tells us that these can be isolated
or they can be mixed together
so for example you could have a set of
power relations in which all three of
these are present and probably
reinforcing each other a great example
of that would be
let's talk about exploitation and
domination together so think about
company towns where the workers were
stuck isolated out in some area they
really don't have any access to the the
wider
world and the company provides them
things and the company puts them into
debt essentially by bringing them in on
the enterprise there are many of these
across the united states in the 19th and
even 20th century
and things sort of like that still go on
in terms of um human servitude
and trafficking as well so the
domination it's backed by force somebody
imposes violence or threatens violence
to another person right and it could be
in this case class based the the not
it's not usually the management who's
directly threatening the workers it'll
be the hired police or you know security
forces of the management and then the
the subjection part could fit in there
as well because it's not enough for you
to be
compliant
and to produce and have you you know get
paid much less than you ought to be paid
for your work so that somebody else can
derive vast profits from it
they also want you to in some sense
be okay with it to recognize it as
legitimate and now that can be gained by
domination recognize it or all beat you
up right
or it could be by tying you into the
forms of exploitation we're going to cut
you in for a bit so see you're getting
your little your taste it can't be that
bad but it can also be in terms of your
own identity
you really don't deserve any better than
this can't you understand that let's go
to you know whatever it's going to be
church
information sessions listening sessions
and one's identity that is is you know
one is being
asked to participate in this is where it
becomes particularly insidious
domination somebody just imposes on you
subjection you are supposed to make a
contribution yourself
and so
becoming uh
institutionalized in that respect where
you can't see things any other way and
yourself any other way could could fit
into that let's talk about each of these
these forms so he mentions
a few different kinds of examples of
domination ethnic religious social
and he says that you know these were
quite common
in a lot of uh you know medieval or
feudal societies so he says there's
there's struggles against this and what
would the struggles look like well he
doesn't spell this out but we could well
imagine it could be of your ethnicity
against the invaders who are coming in
to take you over right one of the things
that was kind of bad about the ancient
medieval
early modern world and still today in
many places is you got other people who
want to take over your your area and
maybe kill you maybe turn you into
slaves subservient class or something
like that
it could be religious as well you know
there have been all sorts of cases where
people impose
a religion on others sometimes it's
coming from who the rulers are they they
say okay everybody's going to shift now
from from this to that or it could be um
you know
religious
and ethnic things tied together some
group comes in takes over now they are
the dominant
religious group and everybody either
becomes part of that religious group or
is subservient to it or has to recognize
certain things
then we can talk about social domination
you know i mean this still goes on today
a prime example of this
is in how for example we treat the
homeless you know they are
pushed off to the side marginalized many
people become homeless and because of
economic things but quite often they're
in fact sort of brutalized and treated
as if they they don't belong anywhere
you know they set up a tent city
cops come in knock everything down beat
them up send them on their way they go
to the homeless shelter they may have to
worry about domination by other people
over them including other homeless and
we could we could come up with many many
of domination you know and how it's
exercised and
when foucault is talking about
resistance to this
or
opposition to this sometimes it's in
terms of the legitimacy people like hey
you shouldn't be violent
shouldn't be doing this to people don't
impose force use reason instead or
persuasion
in other cases it's it's more well i
don't want that guy dominating me or
that group of people dominating me or
that church telling me what to do
right so there's a lot of different
varieties of this and it could also be
within a community you know within a
religious community we're going to
punish you if you don't follow the rules
we'll find ways to make life miserable
for you and then we'll threaten you with
something else happening later on
could be within ethnic groups right so
it's not just ethnic groups against
ethnic groups it could be within it and
that typically does happen
exploitation
is more on the economic front but it's
not purely economic right
and exploitation as foucault says
involves an individual separated from
what they produce so
you know
if you look at
most societies
there's going to be somebody who is
benefiting
from
[Music]
owning the means of production or owning
you know land or owning
other important resources or renting
space to to people
and it's more way more complicated in
our society where we have intellectual
property and all this other stuff going
on where you don't even own your
software anymore coming from the
big five right we just lease it these
days
um but
exploitation is something that that's
pretty well
understood at this point in time but had
to be
you know we had to develop an
understanding of it in the the past and
then we have subjection so let's take a
closer look at this one
he tells us that
we have
struggles against
what ties the individual to themself
and what submits them to others in this
way
he calls this struggles against
subjection
and the french word for that is a
suggestion
against forms of subjectivity and
submission
so what is it what is it to be
subjected in this way
it's not
to be dominated as such it's not to be
exploited as such as a matter of fact
you know
it's it's you there is something
separated from you it's an identity that
somehow gets taken from you and given
back to you
you are this kind of person right
because you said so
or
you you know you went along with it in
some respect
and we could think of all sorts of
examples
of this
so
if you're a student you have a certain
identity
as being a student and there are some
things that are invested in that in your
own self-identity your emotions the
habits that you form you might be a bad
student and you don't study and you're
not going to stay a student for that
long right or if you have enough money
you'll stay a student for a long time
but generally if you're a student
there's certain choices that you're
making there's certain ways you're
defining yourself all your non-student
friends are like hey man it's friday
let's go out and party and you're like
it's exam week i gotta i gotta study for
what's happening next week it's a little
silly example there but it but it kind
of drives it home why do you say no i
can't go and enjoy this this pleasant
activity with you because i've
identified myself in this way and i need
to to do this this sort of thing
and much of our identity is is not this
pure thing that we just sort of come up
with
suey generous on our own right it's
things that we find in our culture and
we take parts and and and we we
use them to make sense of who we are but
when we do that
we exist in a a world of others
and so he says that this submits us to
others
in this this sort of way
now it's very interesting that he tells
us that he says i think in history you
can find a lot of examples of these
three kinds of social struggles as we
saw either isolated or mixed together
when they're mixed one of them most of
the time prevails
so
you know
if there is subjection exploitation and
domination all tied in together
it'll still be primarily about
subjection or primarily about
exploitation and primarily about
domination and these others will be
reinforcing it in some way although
sometimes going against it in some way
as well
so
he tells us that in feudal societies
what we see a lot of is domination it
doesn't completely go away of course
right
as a matter of fact you could say that
one of the key things in a lot of
resistance and liberation movements of
the present
is reacting against the fact that
domination still exists if you think
about the complaints
quite legitimate by feminists about how
they're treated in the household by
chauvinistic men
very often that's you know saying i
don't want to be uh beaten up i don't
want to be raped you know i don't want
this sort of stuff being done to me
and i don't want them the person who's
physically more powerful to get to
manhandle me in that way that's really
protesting against domination it could
still involve exploitation you know
being being uh told that your work that
you're doing in the household doesn't
matter i'm the bread earner therefore i
get to make the decisions it could also
involve subjection you know you better
like not just
go along with this but i want to see you
smiling
but domination is the key element there
whereas in other cases it might be
subjection that's really driving it and
as we say there's the iron fist in the
velvet glove that's the domination part
and exploitation you know let's say
you're in a relationship in one of these
enlightened tech companies and they're
paying you well and you have to take on
certain uh viewpoints about whether you
can unionize or not unionize whether
unionization is a good thing
and about
whether tech companies ought to have the
sort of power that they have that well
that's that's essentially subjection
you know
you should dress like somebody
who actually believes this this set of
mantras
well if you don't do that then
you know you're not going to get good
performance reviews and and
it'll be more exploitative when you work
there and security will kick you out and
we could go on and on so he says that
historically feudal societies have
really been
the struggles have been primarily
against forms of ethnic or social
domination
although economic exploitation could
have been very important among causes of
revolt in the 19th century an industrial
society
the struggle against exploitation came
into the foreground and not just with
marx you know if you actually know your
your history you know that the 19th
century
was filled with social reformers
all sorts of movements marxism just
turned out to be the one that became the
the most popular persuasive and
effective but there are all these other
things where people are like
man this exploitation sucks what are we
gonna do about it right and then he says
nowadays the struggle against the forms
of subjection
against the submission of subjectivity
is becoming more and more important even
though the struggles against forms of
domination and exploitation have not
disappeared
this is quite the contrary that those
are still out there
but now this is where a lot of our focus
is
and he goes on and he says this is not
the first time i think that we've been
confronted with this kind of struggle
and he says all those movements that
took place in the 15th and 16th
centuries which had the reformation as
their main expression and result should
be analyzed as a great crisis of the
western experience of subjectivity
and a revolt against the kind of
religious and moral power that gave form
during the middle ages to this
subjectivity
the need to take a direct part in
spiritual life and the work of salvation
and the truth that lies in the book
all this was a struggle for a new
subjectivity and you could say oh yeah
but wait i thought religion was about
domination of you know one religion over
another like catholics versus
protestants or you know lutherans over
reformed or you know church of england
against quakers or whatever it's going
to be
well yes that's involved but why why are
they sort of at their why are they
trying to dominate each other or to
escape domination because they're also
trying to escape a form of subjection
that's being
imposed
using domination
so this is you know not something
radically new
but we encounter it in all sorts of
other modalities much less typically in
a religious modality and much more now
in terms of
ethnicity or in terms of social class or
in terms of gender or in terms of all
sorts of other things and he says
you know i i understand there could be
objections to this we can say that
all types of subjection are derived
phenomena they're merely the
consequences of other economic and
social processes and he says you know
there's
there's something to that their
mechanisms cannot be studied outside of
the relation to mechanisms of
exploitation and domination
but they're not the terminal of more
fundamental mechanisms they entertain as
he says complex and circular relations
with other forms so there's a
there's its own
you could say
reality
to
subjection as a way in which power
is exercised
on and through us
in power relations
and we we want to be able to distinguish
between these even though in in real
situations they're often tied up with
each other in quite complex ways
you